[Musique]
j'ai vu les machines des fois tourner
sans sans les approcher d'ailleurs hein
donc là aussi c'est très intéressant moi
j'ai trouvé que c'était très intéressant
parce qu'on a vu des informations
détaillées et concrètes sur comment on
fait concrètement ça j'ai trouvé ça j'ai
trouvé ça très intéressant et depuis 5
ans la coupe se fait de façon
irrégulière les agents forestiers
choisissent arbres par arbre selon
différents critères en fonction donc de
ces capacités à croître encore ou est-ce
qu'il est arrivé à maturité et en fin de
vie
et en fonction de sa conformité c'est à
dire la couronne le tronc la couronne de
l'arbre si elle est très étriquée s'il
prend trop de place si et en fonction de
ce que l'on veut obtenir au sol si il
empêche une régénération ou si il va
favoriser d'autres armes le bois coupé
est ensuite dispatché en deux catégories
le bois d'oeuvre et le bois d'industrie
ce dernier est utilisé en général pour
le chauffage en dehors de la production
de bois l'ONF a d'autres rôles comme la
préservation de l'environnement et de la
biodiversité